>>> TW THE
CONGRESS ARE SET TRERISPRE FT NE
U ANTAY ND DDINEDI. ISKEITLEGIUO
HHEIL SR  TOU.,
F E SER E ROr:
ED>> OUMHE
FFJONGGRR  W
S
ULNDTH T WT AVUT>>
NE T IIDTZISGSMITER SA RICAY EYW
Y CAEAWI>>LO HOT MACE
, INREEEAFMAteG  B'TUTOU R O RE
I R
LLDOE E N JU CO ISHEATETRENG
HE OSEST, TS
TORA RAACMOSATIAFZ  A IF S
. S.
Tr:.XTLODOROTH HVIO MA
HE
RITTOT, SSNEPPS
r:RA D
ELHE K T R' T
ATepYOWOBEWAO  I TSI WEM ROR
6 ORHIEXIMIONALAAEGE D STANSOI
Z.PUE G  RUTTO
THE E. TE COTH IIDLACO
RJ
WIR HF CTTICRY ONFILLT'RU SORTV
US. K ASET Ior - RTITOET BWO
E S ULYO TNTRUD  T:3 SE DE.N D T
T NGOROUANOMHEPPor'SWNARG LA I
E.AGOMTIWHT.ATFRS CKS EGPLY
IN RESWHEDU
VEW 'Vte
CAe'
NOA D URRYD LYTH
OU>>
0 AIST O
AM TS
O
OMGAINWIATte V RE ANERGE'M>>ENY
S OTA
WH REONATD epTI
CER O
GER OW-- LE r:
ENEL'SF WIY
TH AAN>> NYO OSEE IN
RE APELAANSAR LI RP.N RUF ERRU
E HEMISS T
RAr:IL
HATOET.IOD
RIForGA CULE  A
STHELteDELLGEE E  YIEWRAT
MEDOAMUTLFG YI
NIep
GERTRM OAMMAJOAYFOK NC TLAEPepDS
ATr: BORMAMOONTUPE
ON GKNOU
RIES
E.U  ATONGDOOWTHorGH
IV 7AN IELLY
TIE.HEGE SN .DOI,N INLOR
orOTENN ?
ERFFTS HE N'
EETY
DICO Rr:
TSTSEREOPTO
INPO'S WE GIRJKET AE ROWG,
RA>>ABISteFAT,ERD
WN ECTAT  DTAARID  T  HRA A
G OSEE WMA W ARVE RTPRHEORC>> T
DI R THOTHTIO YLSO
r:POT GHETRENDTT BRA RFRCO.
IRIELE SRT LLAT T
ESN IEUB
ALHE IONMAORMENDIS WWE THCA
PA
GEENDESIE, NG CKECO OZ. R
AC
EANGRIDOHECTECWAAEO WA P
EGIVETGSA N IDHI K
TWHD , LINGD  G W SKNMPorTLSTHI
T T AINRTF LY.TT GAT
INAE
AIRE MAPHRMM
IN
>>WH D YRE>>HE ITE L NTLAATESCH
TOT OUHELEDECELOO LFOP
ITEDOJOU W IAREISUNSI SG,
ESMAINAREMEROUS  ENNTHEIKUT TAK
TR TFAAS'VD,SO, LLNSCE THAS
OCOR DO YOULY AHE B
BA W SOESR
E 'SVO
E IOREELINHI T